Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个目前正在进行的令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造能够为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）带来的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Today on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, we are looking at how you weigh up which job offer or course offer to accept if you're in the position where you have one or more
这些原则都对你适用。还有由丽莎本人直接送出的精美奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的Linktree链接“Dr. Marianne Trent”，或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有细节发给你。好啦，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）中，我们将探讨如果你处于拥有一个或多个职位或课程录取通知书的情况，
to choose from. I'm guiding you through my top tips and stay right to the end to get all of them. Hope you find it useful. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to episode 75 of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you're listening to this episode when it's freshly available you will now know that it is mid-May and we are approaching the end of the interview season for the Doctorate in Clinical Psychology. A date to remember is the 9th of June. A time to remember is specifically 2 p.mpm on the 9th of June. If you are in the position where you have any offers for doctorate in clinical psychology places, that is the time that you must have accepted your offer. I presume if you haven't, it will be automatically cancelled and your place
你该如何权衡并决定接受哪一个。我将为你介绍我的核心建议，请坚持听到最后以获取全部内容。希望对你有所帮助。主讲人：玛丽安·特伦特博士。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》第75期。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你在这一集刚发布时收听，你现在就会知道现在已经是五月中旬，我们正在接近临床心理学博士（Doctorate in Clinical Psychology）面试季的尾声。一个需要记住的日期是6月9日。一个需要记住的时间是6月9日下午2点整。如果你收到了临床心理学博士项目的任何录取通知书，这就是你必须接受录取的时间。我推测如果你还没有接受，它将被自动取消，你的名额
will be offered to somebody else. So that is most definitely something to be aware of. Now, sometimes people will leave it until the last day because they're trying to decide what is going to be the best fit for them. And of course, this crops up in other areas of psychology as well. Sometimes you might well be in the position where you have more than one job offer and you're trying to decide which is going to be a bit of you. So today's episode is all about that. How do you choose between two job offers? So last week was thinking about should you still, could you, might you, would you still go to interviews if you already had a job offer so if that's what you're looking for you might well find that a useful
将被提供给其他人。所以这绝对是需要注意的事情。现在，有时人们会把决定留到最后一天，因为他们在试图决定什么最适合自己。当然，这也会在心理学的其他领域出现。有时你很可能会面临拥有多个工作机会并试图决定哪个最适合你的情况。所以今天的节目就是关于这个的。你如何在两个工作机会之间做出选择？所以上周我们探讨的是：如果你已经有了工作机会，你是否、能不能、会不会、要不要依然去参加面试？所以如果你在寻找那个，你可能会觉得那一集很有用，
listen that's episode 74 but today is you know you've done well you smashed it out the park you've got at least two job offers or course offers to to mull over okay so let's guide you through this with what I'm thinking is likely to be six key topic areas to consider but you know me may always be a few more if you're watching on YouTube please do subscribe and like this video let me know in the comments what you're thinking what your top tips are if you're listening on audio please do take a moment to rate and review this episode either on apple podcasts or on spotify and come along to the aspiring psychologist community brackets free group on facebook where we can talk about this and a whole lot more too.
那是第74期。但今天是这样的：你知道你表现得很棒，干得漂亮，你至少有两份工作或课程录取通知书需要仔细斟酌。好吧，让我用我认为了解的六个核心主题来引导你思考，但你知道我——玛丽安，总是会有一些额外的补充。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅并点赞这个视频，在评论中告诉我你的想法和你的顶级建议是什么。如果你在听音频，请花一点时间在苹果播客或Spotify上对本期节目进行评分和评论，并来到“有抱负的心理学家社群”（Aspiring Psychologist Community，Facebook上的免费群组），在那里我们可以讨论这个以及更多的话题。
Okay so consideration number one is going to probably be more relevant if these are job offers rather than course offers but if it's for example a master's course that you're trying to weigh up against each other this might well still be relevant for you as well. So it's weighing up the job offers in terms of the job description, in terms of the salary, in terms of you know what it is that's being offered to you and the opportunities that will crop up within that. Where's the location? What are the job hours? What's expected of you? And is that something that you want to consider? So very important factors to consider. And of course, when we spoke about some of the similar issues last week, we're thinking about,
好的，第一点考虑因素可能在面对工作机会时比课程录取时更相关，但如果你试图在两个硕士课程之间进行权衡，这可能仍然对你适用。这就是从职位描述、薪资、所提供的内容以及其中会出现的机会方面来权衡工作机会。地点在哪里？工作时间是什么？对你的期望是什么？这符合你的考虑吗？所以这些是非常重要的因素。当然，当我们上周讨论一些类似的问题时，我们在思考：
well, what's the approach if you've got dependents or if you care for somebody? You know, how inclusive is the employer in that regard how much does it look after your needs point number two is all about company culture now that might well be the employing trust if you're you know looking for assistant work or training course in you know psychological well-being practitioner or something like that or it might be the employer for a private organization for a relevant role in um in the career path to becoming a qualified psychologist or it might be a course it might be a course in counseling psychology doctorate course in counselling psychology doctorate, it might be clinical
好吧，如果你有受抚养人或者你需要照顾某人，方法是什么？你知道，雇主在这方面的包容度如何？它在多大程度上照顾你的需求？第二点完全关于公司文化。现在，如果你在寻找助理工作，或者心理 wellbeing 实践者（PWP）等相关心理培训课程，这可能是雇主信托机构；或者它可能是为职业发展成为合格心理学家的相关角色的私营机构雇主；或者它可能是一个课程，比如咨询心理学博士课程，临床心理学博士课程。
psychology doctorate. What is the university like? What is the employing trust like? Because there's of course those two aspects. Is it a good fit for you? What do the values of that trust or organisation say about them? Do they feel like a good fit for you? One of the interesting things I did recently was look at the Clearinghouse website for how different clinical doctorates talked about themselves. And some of them to me felt a bit oppressive. it felt like really heavy-handed and exact and precise and the ones that for me were a bit more free-flowing and a bit more you know you don't I'm trusting you not to need to know every single detail of what's going to be taught and instead just giving you the themes of what will be taught for me that would be more a bit of what i wanted rather than yeah giving me every
大学怎么样？雇主信托机构怎么样？因为当然有这两个方面。它对你合适吗？那个信托机构或机构的价值观说明了什么？它们让你觉得合适吗？我最近做的一件有趣的事情是查看了清算所（Clearinghouse）网站，看看不同的临床博士项目是如何描述自己的。对我而言，其中一些项目让人感觉有点压抑。感觉非常严厉、准确和精确，而对我来说更自由流动、更随性的那些项目，你知道——我不介意，我相信你不需要知道要教的每一个具体细节，而是只给你教学主题。对我来说，那更符合我的期望，而不是给我每一个
single breakdown point of each lecture i'd ever attend that's um too much for me of course that's going a bit ott they're not going to list every single lecture but certainly all the themes and all of the module titles and things were included and for me that was a little bit much I would rather know about how they treat their trainees or how they treat their staff and what they're hoping I'm going to learn and what you know why I should pick them you know what is it about them that they feel is unique and special and that they do really well that's the kind of things that I'd be wanting to weigh up and of course now is the time for thinking about what others who've gone before
我将要参加的每个讲座的细分要点。那对我来说……有点过头了。当然，这有点夸张，他们不会列出每一个讲座，但当然所有的主题、模块标题等都包括在内了。对我来说，那有点多。我更想知道他们如何对待学员或员工，他们希望我学到什么，以及为什么我应该选择他们。你知道，是什么让他们觉得独特、特别且做得非常出色？这正是我想要权衡的事情。当然，现在是时候思考那些前辈们的说法了：
say about the employer say about the course say about the university itself say about you know departments you're going to be working in you know do you know anyone is there anyone on LinkedIn that you might know who might already have had some experience with this particular and specific offer you've been made and it can be a really good idea to check out the alternative handbook as well to see what people have said about it if it is a course. But that said, of course, people do have different experiences. So you're allowed to still make a choice, even though someone has told you that it wasn't a good fit for them. And sometimes, because it can be really competitive, sometimes we choose to do something that we think might be a little bit tricky because we feel that this is our chance to move on forwards in our career, this is our chance to get our first
他们怎么评价雇主，怎么评价课程，怎么评价大学本身，怎么评价你将要工作的部门？你知道任何人吗？领英（LinkedIn）上有没有什么你认识的人，可能对你收到的这个特定录取有过一些经验？查看替代手册（alternative handbook）以了解人们对它的评价，也是一个非常好的主意。但话又说回来，人们确实有不同的体验。所以你仍然可以做出选择，即使有人告诉你它不适合他们。有时，因为竞争可能非常激烈，有时我们选择做一些我们认为可能有点棘手的事情，因为我们觉得这是我们在职业生涯中向前迈进的机会，这是我们获得第一份助理心理学家面试的机会，
assistant psychologist interview for example and so you might still choose to make a decision which feels like it may not be the wisest most forever permanent choice but I'd say when it comes to choosing a doctoral course that it really should feel as right and like as bit like and like it's a bit of you as much as possible. So point three to consider is all about career growth. So if it's a qualified role then is there you know potentially a perceptorship opportunity to take you from band seven to band eight and beyond is there a potential to go from band four assistant to band five assistant have there been or could there be opportunities for you to to do a specific type of training during
例如，你可能仍然会做出一个感觉可能不是最明智、最永久的选择的决定。但我要说的是，当谈到选择博士课程时，它确实应该尽可能地让你觉得正确、适合你。因此，需要考虑的第三点是关于职业发展的。如果是一个合格的职位，那么是否存在潜在的见习期（preceptorship）机会，能让你从7级（Band 7）晋升到8级及以上？是否存在从4级助理晋升到5级助理的潜力？在课程或角色期间，你是否有过或可以有专门的培训机会？
that course or that role might it offer you the opportunity to do some research within that job role so that you're learning more and getting more to add on your CV as well. If it's a course, do they teach specific modalities which are going to be really useful for you in terms of going forwards in your career after you qualify. It might also at this stage be useful to look at what previous people have done as a result of having done this job or completed this course. Where have they gone to? Where have they flown their wings? What areas do they work in? Again this can be a really useful time to check out LinkedIn. If you're not already connected with me on LinkedIn, do come on over. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Now might be a wonderful chance to take a little moment and to listen to a little jingle.
或者它可能会为你提供在该职位上做一些研究的机会，这样你可以学到更多，并在你的简历上增添更多内容。如果它是一个课程，它们是否教授特定的疗法模块，这对于你资格认证后的职业发展非常有用？在这个阶段，看看以前的人因为做过这份工作或完成这个课程而取得了什么成果，也可能会很有用。他们去哪了？他们飞向何方？他们在哪些领域工作？再次强调，这可能是查看领英的好时机。如果你还没在领英上加我，快来吧。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。现在可能是花一点时间聆听一小段音乐的好机会。
And whilst you're listening to it, if you like it and you're on YouTube, please do like and give me a comment too. I'll catch you on the other side when I will be back along to discuss the three remaining points plus any other musings I've got to. So stay tuned and I'll see you very shortly. I'm the way to get to. So many tips. So many things that you can try. The aspiring psychologist. The aspiring psychologist. Inspiring Psychologist Collective Thank you for listening.
在你听音乐的同时，如果你喜欢它并且你在YouTube上，请点赞并给我留言。我会在另一头等你，回来讨论剩下的三个点以及我的其他任何想法。所以请保持关注，我很快就会回来。这是必经之路。有这么多的建议。有这么多的事情你可以尝试。有抱负的心理学家。有抱负的心理学家。“有抱负的心理学家集体”。谢谢收听。
Thank you for staying tuned. I know a song that will get in your head, get, get, get, get in your head. And I think the same is true with my jingles. So I hope you love them being there as much as I do. In the first half we were guiding you through the first three of my six top areas for consideration when deciding which job offer to accept or which training offer to accept and so this next half is going to be all about guiding you through the next three as well
感谢大家的持续关注。我知道有一首歌会一直在你脑海里盘旋，盘旋，盘旋，盘旋。我想我的音乐也是如此。所以我希望你们像我一样喜欢它们的存在。在上半部分，我们引导大家了解了决定接受哪个工作或培训录取的六大重点的前三点，所以接下来的下半部分将全部关于引导大家了解接下来的三点，
as any other random bits and pieces I can consider to throw in. So this is especially important if you are going to be on a doctorate course for three years and this is about distance, this is about commute. Not everybody can practically afford to or literally afford to pack up their old troubles in their old kit bag and move off to their university town for three years. I did, I did because I was footloose and fancy free but there's many reasons why you might not do that. You might have parents who need your support, parents who maybe are not well, you may have children who are already in schools and you don't want to rock their boats so much. There'll be a variety of reasons. Maybe you're already mortgaged and you really love your home and your environment and
以及我能想到的任何其他随意的琐事。如果你要在博士课程学习三年，这一点尤其重要，这就是关于距离，关于通勤。不是每个人都能在实际或字面上负担得起打包行李并搬到大学镇住三年的费用。我去了，我去了，因为当时我无拘无束、自由自在，但你可能不会那样做的原因有很多。你可能有需要你支持的父母，父母可能身体不好，你可能有已经在上学、你不想过多打扰的孩子。会有各种各样的原因。也许你已经背负了房贷，非常喜欢你的家和环境，
you know that your friends and your networks around you are really going to be a strong, supportive factor for you, protective factors, as we talk about in psychology. And so it might be that you're going to be commuting. And of course, it's useful to know that that might affect how you bond and how you share time with your cohort. So there were a couple of people that did commute in our cohort and it meant that quite often they didn't come to the after University pub gatherings because they had to get back and that did affect their university experience so for me I was able to be you know more going with the flow and you know walking
并且你知道你身边的朋友和网络将是一个强大的、支持性的因素，也就是我们在心理学中谈到的保护性因素。因此，你可能需要通勤。当然，了解这一点可能会影响你与同届同学建立联系和分享时间的方式，这一点很有用。在我们同届中确实有几个人通勤，这意味着他们经常不来大学后的酒吧聚会，因为他们必须赶回去，这确实影响了他们的大学体验。所以对我来说，我能够更加随性，你知道的，在我想去的日子里走着去大学，或者也许在大学后小酌一杯。这些都是需要考虑的因素，但有时人们通过使用Airbnb，或者实际上是B&B，一周住上几个晚上，
to uni on the days when I wanted to be perhaps having a little a little tipple after uni there are factors to consider but sometimes people do make it work with you know airbnbs or actually a b&b and you know staying over a few nights a week so that they can immerse themselves in university and the studying and the requirements of the course whilst still benefiting from their home and their family life for days or for nights a week. So it's got to feel right for you. It's got to be tenable for you and your family because we don't want you to burn out and if you've got you know two hours commute each way plus you might end up on a placement that is like an hour outside of where you live already which might mean you've got three hours each way that's going to be tricky so definitely factors you'll need to consider so if it is a course offer you're trying to weigh up it can be useful to
这样他们就可以沉浸在大学、学习和课程要求中，同时每周还能在家和家人生活中受益几天或几个晚上。所以它必须让你觉得对。它必须对你和你的家人来说是可行的，因为我们不希望你精疲力竭。如果你单程通勤需要两个小时，再加上你最终可能会被分配到一个离你住处一个小时车程的实习地点，这意味着你单程可能需要三个小时，那将是非常棘手的。所以这绝对是需要考虑的因素。因此，如果你在权衡的是一个课程录取，考虑甚至询问这些课程的实习地点在哪里可能会很有用。
consider or maybe even ask the courses what are their areas for placement. So I'm aware that you know for example Solent NHS which covers the Southampton course, Isle of Wight of course is a place that needs mental health provision. And so it might well be that you end up with that as your catchment. And so you might find yourself having to take the ferry across to the Isle of Wight for maybe a few of your placements. And so you'll need to factor that in to your decision making as well. Now you know there are very much more less beautiful places that you could be about to consider living and moving to and having spent a couple of holidays in that nectar woods it is stunning it is sensational and one of my good friends her
据我所知，例如索伦特NHS（Solent NHS），它涵盖了南安普顿的课程，当然怀特岛也是一个需要心理健康服务的地方。所以你很可能会发现那是你的服务范围。因此，你可能会发现自己不得不乘渡轮去怀特岛进行一些实习。所以你也需要将这一点纳入你的决策考虑中。现在你知道，你考虑居住、搬迁和度过的地方可能还有很多更不美丽的地方。在怀特岛度过了几个假期后，那里真是惊艳、轰动。我的好朋友之一，她的
family home is in the Isle of Wight and she sends me the most wonderful videos and photos and sends me voice notes from there and it sounds incredible so it's not all factors to consider as disadvantages you know sometimes we can embrace this moving this relocation as something really special and unique but of course along with the commute comes cost expense. I know that my car is a slightly older model. I drive a 10 year old a month, across a year, across the whole time that you might be living there. And you know how sustainable is that commuting cost going to be for you? Factor five to consider is all about the work-life balance. So if you're trying to weigh up opportunities for employment, where actually some of the culture of the employing trust is that they promote home working, you know, flexible approaches, perhaps, you know, you live close enough that you
家在怀特岛，她给我发了最精彩的视频和照片，还发了那里的语音便签，听起来棒极了。所以这并不全是需要考虑的缺点。你知道，有时我们可以把这种搬迁、重新安置看作是一件非常特别和独特的事情。但当然，伴随通勤而来的还有成本和费用。我知道我的车稍微旧了一点。我开着一辆10年车龄的……一年下来，在你可能住在那里的一整段时间里。你知道这种通勤成本能维持多久吗？需要考虑的第四点是工作与生活的平衡。
can walk to work sometimes, you know, that's going to be advantageous. That was certainly the case when I was most recently employed, that sometimes I was able to walk and that made such an incredible difference. Not all the time. Life's not always that kind to us. But, you know, for the work-life balance, it was pretty incredible. And when it came to choosing between driving, you know, 26 miles each way during really heavy rush hour traffic and then being able to sometimes work from home, sometimes walk and generally be closer to where my family was, even when I was in a base, that was a hard case to answer for so even though it was it meant moving my discipline to adults from children I moved job and even
因此，如果你在权衡就业机会，而雇主信托机构的某种文化实际上是推广在家工作、灵活的方法，也许你住得足够近，可以走路上班，你知道，那将是有利的。我最近一次受雇时肯定就是这样的情况，有时我能够走路，这带来了巨大的不同。并非一直如此。生活并不总是对我们那么好。但是，为了工作与生活平衡，这相当不可思议。当需要在高峰期单程开车26英里并在有时能够在家工作、有时走路以及通常更靠近家人之间做出选择时，即使在我有基地的时侯，这也是一个很难回答的问题。
though it meant moving from a substantive qualified paid permanent contract to moving to a fixed term contract for me it felt like it was worth it because the work-life balance benefits were going to be so brilliant for me and my family. Usually within courses you're probably going to have the same amount of annual leave because it would usually be pretty standard for band six NHS staff if you're employed but there are different courses who do allow you to have some annual leave time within the teaching year and there are others who don't allow it at all so if you know you've got you know family who are likely to to schedule a wedding on a midweek day
所以即使这意味着将我的专业从成人转向儿童，我换了工作，即使这意味着从实质性的、合格的有薪永久合同转变为定期合同，对我来说，我觉得这是值得的，因为工作与生活平衡的好处对我和我的家人来说将是如此棒。通常在课程中，如果你是雇员，你可能会有相同数量的年休假，因为这通常对NHS 6级员工来说是相当标准的，但有些不同的课程允许你在教学年内有一些年休假时间，而另一些则完全不允许。所以如果你知道你的家人很可能会在培训的三年中
across your three years of training and that you'd really like to go then it's maybe just worth considering how flexible courses are about annual leave and again that's something that you might be able to ascertain by speaking to previous trainees. When weighing up job offers from private trusts or hospitals and NHS it's worth looking at their sickness benefits and their pension benefits and how many days annual leave you get for example and whether you get any additional perks. So when I was working for a large psychiatric hospital that was non-NHS, they would give you a celebration day that would mean that you would be able to get an additional day's annual leave. You could choose to take on your birthday or your child's birthday or your anniversary, some day that was important to you which didn't count towards your annual leave allowance
安排在一个工作日的婚礼，而你真的很想去，那么考虑一下课程对年休假的灵活性可能是值得的，这同样可以通过与以前的学员交谈来确定。在权衡来自私立信托、医院和NHS的工作合同时，看看他们的病假福利和养老金福利，以及你获得多少天年休假以及是否有任何额外津贴是值得的。当我为一家非NHS的大型精神病院工作时，他们会给你一个庆祝日，这意味着你能够获得额外的年休假。你可以选择在你的生日、孩子的生日或纪念日，即对你重要且不计入年休假额度的一天休假。
and again that same trust would give you I think it was monetary value in your pay packet for every six months that you'd not had a day off sick for I don't know if they still do that because potentially that might lead to contributing to burnout but certainly at the time it was very useful I think I used to get like an extra hundred pounds or something for not having a sick day and then of course I think if it got to a year I then would be given I think additional day off as well so it might be just worth looking at any individual or specific benefits that come about as part of that job offer or employment. And if you think you might want to become a parent during training, then it might be useful to think about what's gone before you. So of course, it is a job,
同样的信托机构会为每六个月没有请病假的人在工资单中提供我认为是金钱奖励。我不知道他们是否还这样做，因为这可能会助长职业倦怠，但在当时肯定非常有用。我想我以前因为没有请病假而得到大约额外一百英镑左右的奖励，然后当然，如果达到了一年，我想我也会得到额外的一天假。所以看看作为该工作机会或就业一部分的任何个人或特定福利可能是值得的。如果你认为你可能想在培训期间成为父母，那么考虑一下你之前的人经历了什么可能会很有用。所以当然，它是一份工作，
it is a fixed term contract for a doctorate in clinical psychology. And so they do have to treat you like any other staff and there's maternity leave paternity leave all of that jazz but what's gone before you have people tended to defer a year or drop back a year what's gone before you and again chatting to previous trainees can be really useful in that regard I don't know of any male caregivers who have decided to take shared parental leave whilst on training but who knows it might be a possibility if you have done that and you'd like to come and chat on the podcast or you know somebody who has done that please do get in contact because I'd love to chat with you. Last but not least in our six point run through of choosing between two job offers is your gut, trust your gut feeling. How is it feeling to you? How did
这是临床心理学博士学位的定期合同。所以他们必须像对待任何其他员工一样对待你，有产假、陪产假以及所有这些，但你之前的人经历了什么？人们倾向于推迟一年还是退后一年？你之前的人是怎么做的？同样，与以前的学员聊天在这方面也非常有用。我不知道有什么男性照顾者决定在培训期间休共享父母假，但谁知道呢，如果你这样做过并想来播客聊天，或者你知道有人这样做过，请与我联系，我很想和你聊聊。最后但同样重要的是，在我们关于在两个工作机会之间进行选择的六点回顾中，是你的直觉，相信你的直觉。你感觉怎么样？
it feel to be part of the interview processes for both or all of these job offers or course offers that you are weighing up? Which felt more aligned to you? Who treated you in the way that you like to from that interview or if it was remote, what you felt in your body as you shut down your laptop and you went off to make a cup of tea. Did it leave you feeling uplifted, excited, hopeful? Did it leave you wanting to cry? really useful communications and do not shut down your own ability to tap into your gut instinct because it can be really important communications. You know, it's normal that you might feel completely exhausted after certainly a doctorate interview, especially if it's been going on for hours or days, or if it meant that you had to do some element of prep beforehand. So exhaustion, I think, is normal. But if you felt exhilaration, you're tired but exhilarated, that's important communication
对于你正在权衡的这两份或所有工作或课程录取，参与面试的过程感觉如何？哪个感觉更符合你？谁以你喜欢的方式对待你？如果它是远程的，当你关闭笔记本电脑去泡杯茶时，你的身体感觉如何？它让你感到振奋、兴奋、充满希望吗？它让你想哭吗？这些都是非常有用的交流，不要关闭你自己调动直觉的能力，因为它们可以是非常重要的交流。你知道，在博士面试后感到完全筋疲力尽是正常的，特别是如果面试持续了数小时或数天，或者如果这意味着你必须事先做一些准备工作。所以筋疲力尽，我认为是正常的。
in itself as well, I think. So I think in summary you know we're evaluating the job offers, we're looking at the company culture, we're looking at the career growth opportunities for you, we're looking at the commute and how it would impact on you and your life, we're looking at the work-life balance and we're looking at gut feeling. It's also important to know there might well be no right or wrong decision here. You get to choose you know what feels like it's going to give you the best chance of getting to the next stage of your career whatever that might be. If you enjoy this sort of approach, this sort of musing,
但如果你感到兴奋，你累了但很兴奋，我认为这也是重要的交流。所以我想总的来说，我们在评估工作机会，我们在看公司文化，我们在看你的职业发展机会，我们在看通勤及其对你和你生活的影响，我们在看工作与生活的平衡，我们在看直觉。同样重要的是要知道，这里可能没有正确或错误的决定。你可以选择什么感觉能给你最好的机会进入职业生涯的下一个阶段，无论那可能是什么。如果你喜欢这种方法，这种沉思，
this sort of reflection, I think you might quite well enjoy the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And if you're looking for ideas about which jobs to apply for, I think you'll really enjoy the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. So I hope you found this useful. If you've got any questions or any ideas for future podcast episodes, drop them in the comments if you're watching on YouTube or get in contact with me if you're listening. Even if you're watching on YouTube, you can get in contact with me too. I'd love your ideas for future episodes. Thank you so much for being part of my world.
这种反思，我想你可能会很喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership）。如果你在寻找关于申请什么工作的想法，我想你会真的很喜欢《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这两本书。希望你觉得这很有用。如果你有任何问题或对未来播客节目的任何想法，如果在YouTube上观看，请在评论中留言；如果在听音频，请与我联系。即使你在YouTube上观看，你也可以与我联系。我很想听听你对未来节目的想法。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。
And I will look forward to catching up with you very soon for our next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
我期待着很快在下一期《有抱负的心理学家播客》中与你相聚。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。主讲人：玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理 wellbeing 实习实践者。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到这个目标有多少不同的途径，而且没有完美的方式来成为其中一员，这让我大为惊叹。这让我充满信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。